joining us now u.s army combat veteran
he rescued americans from afghanistan
also a congressional candidate from
florida corey mills is with us he's at
an undisclosed location right outside
afghanistan well i cory first of all
i want to say this to you and i got
apparently somebody told me just before
the show time people are criticizing me
for saying this on my radio show
the fact that you
and
retired special ops guys
are willing to put yourself behind enemy
lines
to save americans
i am in awe
of the courage and commitment
and love of country that you're showing
i wish our president shared that love
thank you for your efforts
i hope we can help you in these efforts
my question to you is
they're now taking credit for what
you've done you have a pretty strong
response to them
well first off thanks so much for having
me sean and i appreciate what you had to
say um i was not the organizer or the
leader there was no real leader when it
came to our team uh we are a group of
individuals who have very special skill
sets and backgrounds i was honored to be
a member of that team to help with
facilitating and coordinating some of
the the operations that went on in order
to save this family but you're exactly
right sean if the u.s administration had
done what they're supposed to do it
wouldn't be necessary for guys like
myself or the brave members of our team
we've got guys on our team who speak
five languages we've got guys who spent
decades in special operations and you
know fortunately we were able to rescue
this mother and her three children but
again
no single american should have been left
behind there are more americans that are
still behind the line now we found some
great coordination when it came to the
local
u.s state department that was in the re
the country that we were actually
getting them out but when it came to dc
taking full credit it's just untrue
so tell me about to the extent you can
and i know of things that i really don't
want to talk about the american people
will learn about heroism at a level
that will inspire them i i can say that
um but there are people that have put
themselves in harm's way
trained soldiers the best of the best to
save americans
how do we possibly save if daryl is
right
500 fellow americans how do we do that
well sean i'll tell you that you know we
have quite a few that that we've
compiled on our list we know there's
other teams that are trying to execute
some of the same things that we're doing
uh my understanding was is even glenn
beck who uh you know great american he's
also tried to get over a hundred people
uh the six planes that were at missouri
sharif they were fully manifested
so there is zero doubt that there are
hundreds of americans still behind the
line that still need our help
and again no one left behind
okay what about the state department
obstruction of this rescue flights from
afghanistan they refused to grant
official approval for the private
evacuation flights i i've read about
glenn beck i'm very appreciative of his
efforts anything we can do to help him
glenn if you're watching please let us
know i'll do anything you need
and the department conceded that
official authorization would likely be
needed why would there be any delay for
such a a rescue mission knowing what
we're dealing with here
well again i'm not really sure why they
would prevent such things but i can tell
you that i observed two of these
incidents myself
we had a natural aircraft that was
flying in had an approved ppr
we had an faa flyover approvals
everything that was necessary to land we
were about 9 000 feet off the deck
landing gear down into the descent and
we were told to do a go-around and that
our ppr was disapproved
we were able to through some of the
amazing guys on our team uh applied for
another ppr while in the air get three
more ppr's that were approved that were
immediately disapproved at which point
we were told that the only way we're
landing is if we get approval from the
chairman of the joint teaching staff
general milly himself uh we had circled
for about 15 minutes in the pattern uh i
asked the pilot to land the pilot
basically radioed in that he was going
to land and at that stage that's
whenever they said if you land we will
take your pilot's license we'll take
your aircraft certificate uh and even
had an f-16 up in the air at the time
so that was one of the incidents that
you know that aircraft itself could have
held 25 americans they said that the
excuse was that our aircraft wasn't big
enough sean here's the thing when you've
got a ppr approval that means you
already have a guaranteed landing slot
there wasn't coming you know someone
coming in and replacing our landing slot
so that meant that that's 25 americans
that we had at the gate that we had
ready to go that basically had to find
an alternate method or an alternate
route now the second time after we made
all of our coordinations that our team
gathered everyone up in a safe house and
securely moved them over into mazzara
sharif that's where we had an aircraft
that was already allocated manifest was
finished they were all ready to go and
the state department sent calm command
and the taliban had approved for this
flight to leave at the last minute as
americans were getting ready to get on
that freedom bird that's when the state
department said nope we have to vet the
manifest once more and that flight was
canceled and since then they haven't had
a flight that's gone out
um it's unbelievable i don't think i
think most americans listening cannot
believe what they're hearing i can't
believe it but i do sadly
corey uh godspeed in your efforts if we
can help you in any way or reach out to
our audience to offer you help if you
have any information to pass on will you
please do that
yes absolutely sean and i i can say
there are a lot of americans i'm still
left behind uh the members of our team
are still actually being active and
trying to support that
we're all volunteers we're all here at
our own dimes and trying to do what we
can so
i'd love to try and come back to you and
post something about our foundation so
we can try and get more help to get
these people out
thank you corey appreciate all your
efforts god speed and what you're doing